First, I want to add the original
repository as a remote to my clone, so
I'll copy the URL here.
Then I'll run git remote add.
I'll name the remote upstream, and
I'll paste in the URL I just copied.
Now I'll check out the master branch and
bring it up to
date with the original repository by
running git pull upstream master.
When I run git log, I can see that
the chocolate sprinkler changes here.
Now I'll check out the stop,
drop, and roll branch again, and
I'll merge it with the master branch by
running git merge master stop-drop-roll.
I'll resolve the merge conflict
by adding my stop, drop, and
roll option alongside
the chocolate sprinkler option, and
then I'll get rid of the special lines
and the other versions of the file.
Next I'll add the fire and
commit to complete the merge.
Finally, I'll run git push
origin stop-drop-roll to
push this branch to my fork.
Note that you'll need to push this
to origin, which is your fork.
And not upstream,
which is the original repository.
Since you don't have permission to
push to the original repository.
Since I also want master on
my fork to be up to date,
I'll also check out the master
branch and push that as well.
Now it looks like my pull
request is good to be merged.